this is a five-year-old song this is a
five-year-old video this is a picture of
society five years ago you'll notice the
lack of a deadly virus rampaging
throughout the streets and this is a
five-year-old game i know this isn't
news to anybody but it's still freaking
crazy and what's even crazier is that
after five years of playing this game i
finally come to an epiphany of sorts
which is why i decided to make this half
review half storytelling video or
whatever you want to call it hey better
late than never that's what i always
used to say when i was turning my
homework in high school some of you know
from being around here for a little bit
that my favorite franchise
is zelda
these were the first words on my channel
in fact and this one's about zelda which
just happens to be my favorite subject
by the way
don't don't watch that video just just
don't do it but furthermore some of you
will also know that breath of the wild
is not my favorite zelda game
had a lot of mixed reactions when i made
that tier list a couple months ago and
didn't slot breath of the wild in at the
top but one thing that i've always
wanted to do is explain to you why
breath of the wild is not my favorite
zelda game
the year was 1996. after the omnipotent
powers that be had enough second-hand
embarrassment from american pop culture
in the 90s they decided to give humanity
a blessing the likes of which we had
never seen before and that's why i was
born one of my first memories of life no
joke is sitting on my grandpa's lap when
i was around two or three years old and
playing ocarina of time on
this very cartridge actually now even
though i was a spiritual blessing upon
the world i was still a little kid which
means i was stupid i didn't actually get
anywhere in the game in fact i'm pretty
sure all i ended up doing was running
link into the walls of kokori forest for
hours on end or however long my kid
patience lasted when link would run over
a block and jump or climb up a wall i
thought i was the next era defining
genius i'm ashamed to admit it but i
didn't actually end up beating ocarina
of time until i was much older like
eight or nine years old right before
twilight princess came out listen back
in those days kids like me didn't have
ready access to the internet at that
drop of a hat like kids these days do so
yes it took me forever because i was
stupid but we all kind of were back then
i can't tell you how many hours i spent
just running around the marketplace
talking to everybody i thought that
eventually zelda would come out of the
courtyard and play
she never did the point is i grew up
with zelda being my entire childhood of
course i did have some other games like
super mario 64 or donkey kong 64 or
metroid prime within a couple years and
i loved them all but ocarina of time not
only stuck with me the longest but it
defined what not only an
action-adventure game is supposed to be
but what makes a zelda game a zelda game
and in the years to come when i played
through wind waker or twilight princess
much quicker might i add this was only
enforced since those games expounded on
the best parts of ocarina of time they
had more exploration more dungeons more
music more enemies but the same zelda
formula so here's the part of the video
where we transition into what i thought
about breath of the wild
hello my name is 1000 youtubers i am
here explaining my review of a very
famous game that's already been covered
by 1 000 youtubers
in all seriousness though i realize that
everyone's heard just about every
opinion on breath of the wild under the
sun by now but i'm going to tell you
what i think anyway obviously there was
and still is so much to love about
breath of the wild every time you boot
the game up in terms of gameplay
nintendo absolutely nailed what is
perhaps the most important detail to get
right in an adventure game the feel of
controlling your character i mean it
even felt good to hop around as link
when you're traversing the enormous
world of hyrule having the dedicated
sprint feature from sky resort and a
bunch of other games return to breath of
the wild and tightening up link's
turning radius has produced what is
still perhaps in my opinion the best
feeling third person game i've ever
played to date even when you're riding a
horse through the ridiculously large
fields in the game getting the feel of
riding a wild animal is something that a
lot of games struggle with but in breath
of the wild's case it was this perfect
blend of a little initial learning curve
to how to steer your horse where you
want it to go and tame it and a great
feel to controlling or not controlling
exactly where you want it to go that
auto steer feature is still one of the
greatest quality of life improvements to
controlling an animal in any video game
ever and this isn't even mentioning the
fact that they introduced climbing to
this game coupled with the amazingly
simplistic paraglider i mean it is such
a simple concept but it's freaking
genius because you work so hard to climb
up something and you put all this time
and effort into planning exactly how far
you can go with your current stamina
whether it's raining or not and mapping
out a path over some extremely tall
structures in the game and you slowly
but surely make it up to the top and
once you're up there all your hard work
pays off by giving you a vantage point
from which you can mark places you want
to go in the world glide to places that
you couldn't have gotten to before or
just cover more ground more quickly i
mean i almost feel like it's a metaphor
for life no pain no gain god i gotta hit
the gym and with nearly every surface in
the game being climbable coupled with
the fact that this is one of the biggest
game maps to be ever introduced in a
single player game the sheer amount of
details details details everywhere that
nintendo packed into its map
will just take your breath away no pun
intended but of course nintendo couldn't
allow players to always be able to climb
over stuff because that takes away from
a whole bunch of 3d puzzle ideas which
is something that zelda universe has
been pretty well known for ever since
they made the jump to 3d so in places
where they used the zelda-like 3d
puzzles like shrines or divine beasts
they simply removed your ability to
climb which was a little jarring when
that was literally one of the core
mechanics of the game everywhere else
and i know the surface of the sheikah
structures is apparently too smooth for
link to climb on but
pardon me for going into
super nerdy mode but uh as you can see
given that link is shown to be able to
climb up the smooth surfaces of sand
rock or you know wet ice other places in
the game i just feel like it doesn't
make much sense but you know it's just
one of those things that is what it is i
suppose i mean ultimately they more than
made up for taking away climbing in
those specific locations with the sheer
amount of verticality everywhere else
combat was also brilliantly simplistic
in this game as well finally
capitalizing on those same dodge moves
that the gracefully backflipping link
has been able to do in all the 3d zelda
games up until this point by rewarding a
well-timed dodge with slowed time and
some free damage not to mention it looks
badass as well but before too long your
weapons break now i could ramble on
about the infamous weapon durability
system in breath of the wild
but i'll summarize it for you by saying
just this while i understand completely
why a lot of players out there were
extremely frustrated by this it never
really bothered me all that much
probably because i was always killing
things and getting their new weapons
because killing things is fun it was fun
to swing around a giant two-handed
weapon and sometimes a one-handed blade
or blunt weapon or a two-handed jabbing
spear every time your weapon would break
it would force you to switch to
something else and there was just enough
variety in weapon drops that it always
kept things fresh and i don't know
feeling nice to me and i honestly
enjoyed it because it also makes you get
better with all sorts of different kinds
of weapons in the game plus i mean if a
weapon broke you could quickly swap
weapons to whichever other weapon you
had in your inventory at the click of a
button and it paused time for you no
matter how many enemies were right
around you trying to cut your giblets
off i mean what could be more convenient
motion controls were married to the
analog stick in holy matrimony you could
aim your bow shot or weapon throw over
long distances by controlling it with
the analog stick but then zero into the
fine shot with just the movements of
your wrist at the same time and because
of this since you could use the stick as
well as your wrist you never had to
press a button to recenter your aim
unlike some games and one of the coolest
things about the game was the fact that
the entire world was a physics engine
sandbox that worked extremely well
most of the time and i'm not just
talking about some items having physics
applied to them like bombs that can roll
around like in previous zelda games
literally everything besides like big
buildings has calculable mass in game
applied to it that can be manipulated
with all the tools that they give you in
game to manipulate physics i mean just
check out video game donkey's video
about breath of the wild the dude uses
korok leaves and octorok balloons to
make flying ships i mean
what one of the coolest things that
video games have been evolving into more
and more over the years is physics
engines and pretty much any game that
introduces a good one is guaranteed to
be at least somewhat of a hit just
because of how much fun you can have
with virtual physics where you can be as
destructive as you want to be with none
of the repercussions from real life case
in point half-life 2 or halo 3 and i
know those two games are great for a
bunch of different reasons but one of
the big reasons for both of them is
their phenomenal physics systems in
breath of the wild you can drop boulders
on enemies and chuck battle objects
through the air the physics engine
handles it all perfectly you can freely
manipulate metal objects through the air
or freeze items and even enemies in
place to create some truly truly
memorable moments and even the music of
breath of the wild was something that i
wasn't exactly a fan of at first but
i've gradually learned to appreciate
more than anything recently and i'm not
even talking about the amazing music
from the trailers lots of people
criticized the game for not having like
a catchy hyrule field theme for instance
like in the previous titles but that was
actually a design choice from the
developers of breath of the wild because
of the way that the game is designed
players spend lots of time in big open
areas that are all the same area because
those areas are so massive in case you
haven't noticed what was once hyrule
field is now the world of hyrule so
hearing the same three-minute loop of
trumpets blasting and whatever for a
hyrule field theme would probably get
old after oh i don't know two hours or
so of gameplay and they still made
unique catchy memorable tracks for a lot
of their uh specific places like gerudo
town or rito village or zora's domain or
their character themes like the music
for urbosa or mifa which ties into her
little brother saidan's theme no joke
it's actually quite the fascinating
sorry about that it's actually rather
fascinating is what i was trying to say
to dive into all of the
thought and and structure and
development that went into the music of
breath of the wild in fact i actually
narrated a video from reuben wagner here
on youtube delving into this very
subject so if you're interested in
learning more about the music of breath
of the wild i will link to that in the
description below i'm sure you've heard
this a hundred times before and you're
gonna hear it 100 more times but really
the feeling the experience of playing
breath of the wild is absolutely
unparalleled that feeling that you get
from discovering a new biome or coming
across a big new enemy camp and deciding
exactly how you're going to take them
out and the changing weather and the
climbing and the discoveries and the all
of it is just
a priceless experience and in my opinion
the very reason why it won game of the
year 2017 and it's true it didn't
introduce anything new to gaming as a
whole i mean countless other games have
had music and armor and exploration etc
but breath of the wild capitalized on
certain concepts of open world gaming
and absolutely knocked them out of the
park and into outer space however this
is where we change gears because there
are many concepts that i believe
nintendo could have handled much better
in breath of the wild a lot better
actually
in the first place it does feel a bit
odd that nintendo toyed with the concept
of different levels of difficulty for
enemies and different levels of weapons
but yet didn't introduce like xp for
link i guess technically spending the
four spirit orbs in game to get a heart
container or a stamina vessel is
leveling up for link but it's the fact
that completing shrines is specifically
the only way to do this that's the
problem see normally in action-adventure
open-world rpg games of an extremely
similar caliber you're able to level up
by gaining experience which is awarded
to you for doing all sorts of different
things things that breath of the wild
also features in the game in skyrim for
instance you can fight monsters and
explore dungeons and roam about the map
and even craft all sorts of items all of
which gives you xp which in turn gives
you more damage more health more magic
levels this gives the player incentive
to kill all the enemies in a camp or to
explore every single room in a dungeon
or even just exploring the different
parts of the map because no matter what
you do you're not wasting time because
you gain xp and your character gets
stronger for it which makes it worth it
even if you don't find a new weapon or
piece of armor that you fall in love
with in breath of the wild it doesn't
matter how many monsters you kill or how
many dishes you cook because the only
thing you'll ever gain from doing those
things is monster materials which are
nice of course until you have literal
hundreds of all of them or weapons which
you do need a lot of because they break
very quickly or dishes which are nice
until you get armor which renders
literally any dish completely useless
except for temporary stamina and health
dishes those will always be useful but i
feel like the lack of a level up system
for link based on xp negatively affected
my drive to clear out every enemy camp
that i came across after about
mid game and onward because by that
point i had pretty powerful weapons and
i had enough monster materials to cover
the upgrades that i needed and i didn't
want to spend the time or weapons
frankly to clear out every single
monster that i came across not to
mention a lot of the chests that you
uncover in the game have rewards that
are kind of lackluster or not quite as
good as what you have so there simply
wasn't a reason to open every single
chest anymore not to mention the pretty
blatant lack of diversity in breath of
the wild's enemies which led to enemies
becoming
kind of boring to fight again after
about midway in the game see even though
a bokoblin or a moblin can reappear
later in the game as a red than blue
than black than silver than gold if
you're an expert hard mode player they
all use the same kinds of weapons and
the same attack patterns against link so
after early game you get used to
fighting any one of these kinds of
enemies the only real difference between
their colors is their health pool here's
a little frame of reference for you in
breath of the wild and i'm going to
refer to my notes here there are 98
total different enemies that includes
world bosses and all the versions of
ganon as well but when you cut out the
duplicates like you know the multiple
colors or the multiple different kinds
of the same enemy that are just
different elements you are left with 28
different kinds of enemies in the game
for comparison in ocarina of time you
know a game that came out 19 years
before breath of the wild there were 87
total different enemies in the game or
64 when you cut out the duplicates
that's well over twice the amount of
unique enemies in breath of the wild in
twilight princess which came out 12
years before breath of the wild there
were 107 total enemies or 84 unique
different kinds of enemies when you cut
out the duplicates that is literally
three times the amount in breath of the
wild but yet breath of the wild's huge
world was nearly 380 times larger than
twilight princesses and over 3
600 times larger than ocarina of times
let that sink in for a second combine
this kind of painful lack of enemy
diversity with the fact that you don't
gain xp from killing enemies and you're
left with the answer of why i got bored
with fighting in breath of the wild
before too long and speaking of breath
of the wild's huge open world it did
introduce a new kind of open world
experience to the legend of zelda but
let me explain what i mean by that
because technically speaking the legend
of zelda as a franchise has always had
open world gameplay ever since the first
game in the original you were able to
literally go left right up down wherever
you wanted exploring whatever dungeons
in whatever order you wanted to the
series did begin to focus more on linear
storytelling around the time of a link
to the past and onward when it
introduced heavier in-game storytelling
but you've still always been able to
pause the main storyline and go explore
the world and complete side missions at
your disposal and this is the same style
of open world gameplay that other
extremely popular open world games like
skyrim or gta or eldon ring adopt as
well after all there's nothing quite
like having the power of choice to just
pause everything that's going on in the
world in order to catch a hylian loach
or ask a weird guy in the woods for an
odd mushroom but even though the zelda
games all the way up until skyward sword
featured this open world concept at
least in regards to exploration and side
quests just locked behind a few gadgets
every now and then they never allowed
their open world gameplay to take away
from their acquired style of telling the
player the story by having the player
play through the story linear
storytelling that's where the open world
of breath of the wild differs for the
first time in the series since a link to
the past linear storytelling was
sacrificed in favor of this new version
of open world gameplay right off the bat
when you start the game and you raise
the great plateau tower you are
immediately shown the end game fight and
its location there's ganon right there
looking like an angry cloud monster but
nintendo had to reveal this right out
the shrine because after you complete
the only real thing that you have to do
in the game which is the first four
shrines and you know the great plateau
section you really are 100
completely free to do whatever you want
whenever you want at your pace this is
breath of the wild a true open world
experience you even get the quest to
defeat ganon right off the bat which
kind of made a lot of people chuckle
when they saw it and you can do it if
you want to you know where he is it's
even marked on your map and the most
powerful weapons and equipment are in
hyrule castle right around again and so
there's not much reason to gear up
anywhere else in the world unless you
want to do shrines and get more hearts
and stamina and i've gotta admit
that didn't sit super well with me
because due to my perspective on zelda
games which i acquired over the course
of my entire childhood like i was
talking about earlier
i was expecting something different in
all of those trailers leading up to the
release of the game we got to see hints
of epic climactic battles and amazing
music and this cast of new characters
that i couldn't wait to get to know the
story of breath of the wild had
everything it needed for a fantastic
narrative arc according to this chart
here as you can see effective
storytelling works best when you build
tension with crisis after crisis after
crisis slowly just having everything
bubble under the surface until
everything bursts with the final climax
after which you have the resolution be
it good or bad breath of the wild had
this
100 years ago when link wakes up aka
when you come into the picture and start
playing the game you're somewhere out
here you do hear zelda's voice like
speaking to you in your mind and urging
you to go defeat gannon because she's
getting kind of tired but at the same
time you've got all this world in front
of you to explore and and what's that is
that snow is that snow i see over there
have we ever had snow in a zelda game i
want to go see what that's all about and
zelda's been effectively keeping the big
bad bore cloud at bay for the past
century so what's a few more weeks am i
right and yes it is true that while you
explore the expansive world of hyrule
you can discover the 13 forgotten
memories of link and try to piece
together the story of what happened 100
years ago but the point here is that the
impactful
emotional weight that comes from playing
through a narrative that we've seen work
in other open world games and
specifically other zelda games was
sacrificed in breath of the wild all to
become one word non-linear and the
question we have to ask ourselves is
was it worth it is the enormous world of
hyrule big enough and cluttered enough
with enough content to merit the fact
that they changed up and took away their
storytelling on the one hand yes because
of several reasons see my previous
section when i praised breath of the
wild non-stop but on the other hand
no because breath of the wild's huge
world that's filled with verticality and
hidden areas to explore is also lacking
just
content listen there are 900 korok seeds
to find
in the world 900 and yes i know that
nintendo put that
massive amount in the game not so that
you'd find every one of them but so that
you didn't have a choice but to stumble
across a lot of them but
that's really all they did
with the open world when you're
exploring the vast wildernesses in the
south or the mountains to the west and
east or the canyons to the southwest
you'll run into one of four things a
korok some enemies an npc or a shrine
and the nbc's that you do meet only ever
end up speaking a few lines of dialogue
or needing to be saved from enemies or
giving you a quest that will reward you
with a material or a cooking dish that
you can get from literally anywhere else
in the game and yes i understand there
are a whole lot of nbc's in breath of
the wild like a staggering amount of
npcs in breath of the wild but to quote
my previous breath of the wild review
video the point is what's better a bunch
of characters with little development or
a few characters with a lot of
development the classic argument of
quality versus quantity which will
always be debatable by nature in
previous zelda games and even non-zelda
games like the often mentioned skyrim or
eldon ring exploring the world results
in finding all sorts of unique stuff
like other dungeons or other unique npcs
or just
things which are completely missing from
breath of the wild in exchange for
shrines which are each shorter than
dungeons but there are lots more of them
again quantity over quality eldon ring
for example knocked the concept of
content in the open world out of the
park i mean seriously around every
single bend in every corner and on top
of every hill and under every bridge
there are just gobs of unique items npcs
monsters it's it's a stack it is
actually legitimately overwhelming okay
i'm having a meltdown just thinking
about all the different things i've come
across in eldon ring personally and on
the other hand breath of the wild has
korok seeds which are poop i'm not even
kidding korok seeds are literal poop
because of this lots of fans of the
series call breath of the wild's open
world empty and it hurts me to admit it
but
i actually agree plus there was a very
large opportunity in breath of the wild
that was completely missed out on and
that would be the villain of the game
you remember that saying that a hero is
only as good as the villain well it's in
terms of storytelling it means that a
good villain is a great catalyst to push
the hero or the story or just everything
forward that much better in order to
really vibe with a fictional world or a
fictional story especially one that
deals with good and evil you need a
really good villain that can push the
hero of the story into challenging
waters and you need one that's capable
of making intelligent decisions and even
challenging your morals sometimes you
know like ganondorf from the wind waker
for instance but doing this sort of
thing requires you know a brain
and i'm not sure calamity ganon has one
except for you gannon you definitely
have a brain
i think
the ganon and breath of the wild is
mindless almost like an idea of evil as
an entity rather than an entity with
evil ideas there's a reason why
everybody freaked out when ganondorf was
revealed to be in breath of the wild 2
via the first trailer in
we're all thirsty for an intelligent
villain to return to the series and also
to see if he rehydrates the point is the
empty feeling world of breath of the
wild could use a huge injection of
enemies an xp system dungeons npcs and a
much better villain but i've said enough
at this point you've all heard this
stuff before ultimately though even
though i had
more i guess negative things to say
about breath of the wild than positive
unfortunately that does not mean that i
didn't like the game i loved the game
even back in the day five plus years ago
when i played the game for the first
time and made that first review video
which you should definitely not watch i
always thought it was a really really
really good game just not
a super blow me out of the water
great
game
something big happened earlier this year
my girlfriend happened and no we didn't
get together this year we've actually
been dating since 2016 but this was the
year that she decided to play
an actual video game let me explain this
girl bless her heart was raised on mario
kart and disney movies and there's not a
damn thing wrong with that and i think
she may have even played super mario
brothers on the wii growing up but that
was it she never once touched a
controller to play any sort of single
player or adventure game of any sort
much less a zelda game the horror
because of this and this is not a slant
against her family or anything i love
them to death and people have a right to
be into whatever they're into but
because of this she grew up thinking you
know video games are just
things that you grow out of right i mean
you got to grow up sometime but this
year after many requests from me over
the years she finally decided to open up
to the notion of playing a video game
that isn't a racing or arcade style game
so we bought her a switch oled and i
recommended breath of the wild to go
with it because it's new and it's a
zelda game and it's streamlined and it's
fun and it's a zelda game and we fired
it up and let me tell you i think the
first few moments of watching someone
who's never controlled a character in
third person
try to walk down the steps outside the
shrine of resurrection and continually
just fall and plummet to their death
over and over again
is something i will never forget and i'm
sure she won't either because after
about the 12th time she was getting a
little frustrated actually it's a
testament to good video game design on
nintendo's part because it teaches
players to be able to walk alongside
cliffs and not you know plummet to their
deaths but she was a trooper and no
matter what stuck with it at first just
because i asked her to she's good people
i'm a lucky guy i got to watch as she
went from completely new to controlling
a third person view game in general and
even combat and video games aside from
jumping on goombas to being able to
sprint and jump alongside mountaintops
without missing a step best lionel's in
combat and snipe moving enemies from
afar and that's when something began to
change in me see not only did she begin
to develop skills for video games as a
whole because of this brilliantly
designed 3d action adventure game but
she also began to develop a love and
connection to the game world before too
long she would start asking me if she
could play breath of the wild instead of
you know watching a movie or a tv show
which made me extremely happy to see of
course she began to make references to
the world of breath of the wild or maybe
its characters in general unrelated
conversations that we would have in the
middle of the day and she refused to
fight calamity ganon and complete the
game until she discovered all 120
shrines and uncovered all 13 memories
all on her own i watched this game and
its world and its characters and its
enemies and its music and its structure
and its exploration
captivate her and convince her that
video games are beautiful works of art
that should be enjoyed by people of all
walks of life from all backgrounds and
of all ages breath of the wild did in a
single play through what i could not do
for years and that's when it all hit me
i was wrong about breath of the wild it
is a great game it's one of the greatest
games i've ever had the honor of playing
actually but let me clarify something i
don't think i was wrong to compare it to
previous zelda games i don't think
anybody was wrong to compare it to
previous zelda games i mean
it does have zelda in the title the
zelda franchise had nearly 20 entries in
it before this game came out it's only
natural for fans of the games from
before breath of the wild to compare the
newest entry in the games to the games
that were already out how can you not
compare something that is a part of an
already established franchise with that
of franchise's name to itself but on the
other hand why can't a franchise expand
and evolve into something newer and
greater it's the same for breath of the
wild on the one hand it is perfectly
natural to compare it to its
predecessors like ocarina of time or
twilight princess and get in all the
nitty-gritty of how dense the world is
per capita with enemies or korok seeds
or whatever but on the other hand once
you get past all that comparison and
really just
[Music]
focus on breath of the wild for breath
of the wild's sake you begin to see why
it's so beautiful you know what my
girlfriend said when i mentioned to her
that i thought breath of the wild's
world was empty she just kind of blinked
and said that she actually felt that it
was so cluttered that she almost found
it overwhelming the story was rich and
deep and she didn't mind that she didn't
play through it because to her she was
still experiencing it in a way by
piecing it together the voice acting in
the cutscenes never failed to captivate
her and grab her attention and keep her
eyes locked on the screen more so than
when she had to read through dozens and
dozens of lines of text boxes and the
shrine's reach fresh and new and
challenging and covered concepts that
she wasn't previously used to and were
never long enough to become overwhelming
see
i was wrong about what breath of the
wild had set out to do nintendo decided
that they wouldn't pigeonhole the zelda
franchise with the zelda formula any
longer which is something that i can
kind of respect since that's something
i've been struggling with myself on the
platform it didn't set out to beat the
previous zelda games it set out to reach
new people people like my girlfriend who
loved the shrines and loved the enemies
and loved the music because she didn't
compare them
to the other dungeons or the older music
or the older enemies from the previous
zelda games perspective is everything
because beauty is in the eye of the
beholder it's a life lesson that i don't
think i'll ever forget so anyway it took
me five years and a girlfriend willing
to try something out simply because i
asked her to before i was able to
realize the real beauty that is breath
of the wild at the end of the day i
still don't think breath of the wild is
my favorite zelda game because that
requires me to compare it to the
previous zelda games which i enjoyed for
all the different reasons that i spent
this entire time detailing but at the
same time i think breath of the wild
just might be
the greatest game i've ever played in
general that probably doesn't make any
sense unless you're really vibing with
me right now in which case it probably
makes perfect sense anyway if you're
still watching thank you and
congratulations i'm a bit of a rambler
so this one ended up being a little bit
longer than i was anticipating but there
was just a lot to say in cover about my
journey from breath of the wild's
release up until now if you had a
similar journey or feel the same way or
feel differently i would love to read
about your experience in the comments
below or if you just want to geek out
about your favorite zelda game feel free
to place that down there as well if
you'd like for me to make more videos
where i review games or talk about my
experiences also let me know because
there's a lot of opinions that are up
here in this noggin of mine and i can
talk for a long time subscribe if you
haven't already to stick around for all
sorts of new videos about new video
games to come and a hearty welcome to
the newest member of my bandit crew
donnie j that's about all i've got for
this one so as always i hope you have a
wonderful rest of your day this is
bandit looking forward to seeing you
next time and signing out
[Music]
you